quella tutti ragazzi e porca eva se
magari tengo il microfono più vicino non
mi sentite no magari se metto anche le
cuffie porca vacca non so fare lo
youtube lazio è tardi cosa non sei più
che devo andare a scuola se mia madre
amica sono sei tu zio dove sei questo ha
bevuto ieri non si ricordato ha dormito
sonni sono in una casa dove il tipo non
si ricorda di aver dormito ragazzi
allora dobbiamo capire dove stiamo di
sicuro non siamo a casa mia e va beh vi
qualcuno mi spiega come ci entrato in
questa stanza sto tizio non lo volesse
però c'è una torcia grazie a dio una
torcia almeno vedo qualcosa avrà pur
bravo c'è della nebbia
c'è del fumo cos'è sta roba c'è del fumo
e mezzo all corino io capisco sono lo sa
lui dove si è svegliato saprei io ma ci
mancherebbe altro guarda messo
[Musica]
no no no no no dai dai che ci sono il
porto e la sole invece di essere
sintonizzati su radio mohamed perché non
spegniamo la radio esatto potrebbe
essere un buon modo per proseguire tutto
chiuso porca la vacca e valenza e chiuso
questa chiusura è come esco io
ma ammette dammi una mano ma ahmed
grazie momento non ho parole
la chiave a ok a perfetto che egli però
ho capito
vai vai veloce l'ace vieni qua allo
ragazzi mohamed el abbiamo passato
abbiamo capito che siamo in hangover non
ho capito chi si aggira in questi posti
perfetto adesso forse sì salve sono se
sei in un gioco horror e sei da solo in
un posto dove non sai come ci sei
arrivato c'è qualcuno zombie che cammina
di certo non urli testa di mino la
parole cioè non ha veramente senso stare
[Musica]
vandali devo andare proprio 18 le c'è
stato chi oggi si scricchioli no raga vi
prego iddio che sembrava tipo uno zombie
non si è decisamente uno zombie
richiedi di urlare perché si stupido
perché ti hanno fatto stupido
porca vacca laida dov'è andata quel
ciclo c è una femmina assieme ai capelli
lunghi effettivamente
mai è tutto chiaro e io non me la cavo
molto bene con le donne però io so che
le ragazze in un certo periodo del mese
è passato un brutto periodo ecco se
siete delle ragazze è passato un brutto
periodo per favore non strisciate per
terra perché potrebbero esserci dei
problemi grossi molto grossi questi
problemi e soprattutto non pestate
quello che buttate fuori dove c'è prima
fa c'era un'altra porta che ovviamente
sparita
non lo so zio però ci sono questa porta
entriamo in questa bene corridoio più
allegro meno male allora io non so dove
sia andata la tizia il problema è che
però grazie dio il maestro è sparito
ancora no
e va beh ciao zia si sono incazzate le
ragazze nel periodo chiudi veloce corri
velocissimo no vabbè vabbè non sono un
maschio semplice non vi capisco voi
donne successo mi ha ucciso e va beh non
posso far niente c'era il muro praga era
cosa veramente orribile cosa devo fare
non non c'e niente dietro la porta e
cosa faccio al meglio la radio non ci
credo ci voglio credere
cioè armadio
salve non sono per niente nell'arma
nell'unico armadietto che c'è nella
stanza non sono mica li penserai mica
che sono lì perché ti sbagli grosso zia
infatti non c'è cascata è possibile è
scema
no no non si fa questa cosa sui muri non
si fa neanche sui muri ragazze non usa
ok che questo tipo continua a parlare mi
dà fastidio fatemi capire dove devo
andare a di quanto vale keanu bene ti
guardano non avevo dubbi zio che cosa mi
serve le forbici forbici cosa il rumore
è questo velocissimo via via via via via
via bye bye bye porca eva è la tua madre
oppure oddio libro flip challenge veloce
s'è chiusa
non so dove sia la tizia però queste
sono le più brutte infradito che abbia
mai visto
spesso queste chiusa
[Musica]
non lo voglio sapere zio che cos'è quel
rumore non lo voglio sapere via in
attimo perché va c'è un condotto a no
non posso staccarlo avuto le mani zio
madonna che bracci scommetto che lei nel
suo periodo riesci a staccarti anche il
muro però è un dettaglio così io posso
entrare quadri di sicuro non entro nella
sua era qua prima bello mi fa piacere
comunque zia ci hai dei problemi se tu
sei il cesso che a un centimetro perché
devi maestro area un centimetro di
fianco se deficiente c'è il cesso vai lì
non capisco piede di porco la più grande
invenzione dell'uomo dopo dopo il mestro
per terra
magari se tolgo la torcia
vale ancora il discorso di prima il
cesso celaya un centimetro perché
sbocchi per terra vabbè fa niente
mi spiace per chi dovrà pulire e di
certo non sono io veloce che bella
questa animazione del piede di porco che
si che scrosta il letale tegole da solo
bravissimo perfetto quanto mi devo
aspettare un jobs che erano momento
all'altro quanto me lo devo aspettare è
già qualcosa
[Musica]
oggi ai to be to be haters senza
perché devi stati parlare stai zitto
cosa dovrebbe farci una bambola schifosa
nell'angolino di un condotto
[Musica]
ripensandoci la bambola non è più un
problema
ma ringraziando iddio è uscita perché
sta piangendo
io devo per forza andare dove va la
tizia quale problema o lo sapevo lo
sapevo
grazie a dio ho visto al marito quando
sono entrato grazie a dio
no non lo vuole sapere dove no
è lo zio che navigare nel maestro nel
massimo delle tue aspirazioni però ci
hai dormito tu in questo posto cazzi
tuoi
ho visto john hopkins devo usare sta
roba per uscire
come faceva a saperlo proprio come come
come l'avevo già capito già prima
qualcosa
quello sì questo no porca eva ma
veramente brutta regala cosa più brutta
via m'vila cos'è che schifo come nuotare
nel maestro tutorial by salvatore
aranzulla
vabbè questa cia la schiena leggermente
incriccata vabbè ma fuori a riuscire dai
muri la capiamo non so perché mi fa
ridere ragazzi mi fa scassare non ha
senso come si muove perché i movimenti
chalme chiamare anche thriller di
michael jackson è uscita posso uscire ha
aperto la porta proprio ma in teoria tu
potresti strisciare questo solo che 6p
globo nello schifo proiettori a potresti
passarci solo pigro maledetto
basta devo fare qua
fold
a pozzo spia
posso sbirciare negli angoli ma magari
non farlo quando c'è la tizia ecco mi ha
visto
cosa non va donna stava smistando le
stava andando in bocca come ho fatto con
la loro idea lo tratta porta veloce race
cazzo lo aveva visto non sa come e cerca
cazzo veramente non e idee veramente mi
aveva praticamente preso non so come ho
fatto
non male che c'e l'armadietto lì non
mettiamo la radio con movimento in
questo momento fusibile una carezza mi
serve per aggiustare la porta ha
permesso
[Musica]
non c'è non mi prende non li prende non
mi prendo mi prendo mi prende non mi
prende lo so io
non entra alla è stupida come si faceva
sbirciare prima
ok magari se fai dietrofront e un attimo
mi fai un piacere sia grazie
gentilissima ci passa di qua se ci passo
veloce veloce madonna che culo dove non
la vedo ok
bye bye
perfetto dio santo corri fotte sega vai
zio vai zio apri devo ammetterlo quale
il fusibile sì per forza grazie che di
queste animazioni bellissime non potevo
farne a meno
veloce veloce veloce
perfetto mai mai mai vice ceo vecchio
vecchio menti capaci di aprire anche
questo
basta
dai carri ma pensiamo sul tavolo da solo
invece loro vincere o non vincere una
misura il vicino come cina cazzola
uscita non ci vogliono no non è
possibile
cos'è successo dove la tipa ma mi spunta
dal muro quanto è vero iddio lo so io
tanto lo sapevo
qua subito russo scaricando già concluso
poi video grazie per aver partecipato a
questa esperienza bella soprattutto
molto tranquilla però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi come si dice nel
momento e mi piace anche vari social
come schizzare tutte le sedi siete lì ci
vediamo a un prossimo vito sperando di
non svegliarci imposti schifosi vabbè da
ragazzi